father first of all congratulations a
difficult match against Irina but you
bounce back immediately with a crucial
Victory against nemesova how did you
approach today's match
uh I feel like this match was very
similar to last year
okay I also played catcher in the last
year and I was under a lot of pressure
in the first game it's very hard to
predict what she will do she plays kind
of systems she doesn't really play a lot
of theoretical stuff so I reviewed a lot
of things not the one that she played in
the first game I my position was quite
tough but then when things got messy I
think I got the upper hand and second
game I was again getting out played
which is what exactly what happened last
year that I won the first game second
game I was getting out played but were
you getting any flashbacks from yeah
yeah when I was playing it it was like
all coming back to him because it was
also like kitchen versus night and then
like again like I had a pun breakthrough
and then one of my pawns uh Queens so it
was like exactly the same thing but they
both worked it out it was good at what
point did you feel like you can breathe
a sight of uh relief in the final game
um yeah I'm in here
I mean I feel like I don't know it's
just I feel like here I'm just getting
out played somehow
it's still a very powerful night yeah
more of a closed semi-close Center we go
to a position and then
what to do
King juton then I realized she was 93 or
Knight of four even so I'm just walking
into the tactics I'm like okay then I
wanted to go H4 something yeah yes you
have 93.4 yeah it just wins
exchange or the queen and I wanted to go
H4 but then H4 like takes away this some
queen d8 queen H4 Perpetual ideas that's
the thing when you have this idea that
you want to play with for a draw it just
kind of influences how you play but
maybe H4 is more of a normal move at
some point I can go H5 like if she goes
King f8 then I have H5 Queen H7 maybe
something
yeah get some counterfeit because
otherwise I just don't know what to move
because my queen side is still under so
much pressure at the same time playing
the move H4 weak on zero position a
little bit and it's difficult to make
with so little time on the clock you
play the H3 and you entered this uh end
game
yeah I think we should we're just
feeling safe at this point no still not
safe
um
yeah because she has a knight and we
have no time and it's so tricky with
nights yeah yeah okay once I went to
five I thought I was okay and then and
then I realized oh she's just like
that's what she did but then I was like
oh the G7 plus I'm you know this carol
conversations where you get the
structure and I was like okay I didn't
even calculate I was like it just has to
work out for me somehow this age Pawn is
going to run down the board
thought of congratulations uh tomorrow
uh you know who you're going to face or
I thought I'm not playing tomorrow not
playing you're getting arrested
a well-deserved rest day for you guys
any questions for our Victor our
congratulations start to have good luck
in your next elimination match
thank you yeah
um